so you've been married four times yes
and divorced four times yes and would
you need any help with lawyers I can
tell you Oh Christie Brinkley offering
up her divorce attorneys digits to Wendy
Williams on her talk show Tuesday during
the break I have one but I want to hear
what you said
just hours earlier Williams estranged
husband Kevin hunter broke his silence
issuing a statement to ET hunters words
come less than a week after Williams
revealed she had filed for divorce amid
speculation that hunter had been
cheating on the talk-show host with a
woman who allegedly gave birth to his
baby last month hunter wrote in part
quote I am NOT proud of my recent
actions and take full accountability and
apologized to my wife my family and her
amazing fans I am going through a time
of self-reflection and am trying to
right some wrongs he went on to explain
quote I will continue to work with and
fully support my wife in this business
and through any and all obstacles she
may face living her new life of sobriety
while I also work on mine it's so crazy
because now my business is your business
got Aparna Williams who recently
revealed that she is living in a sober
house spoke out for the first time since
filing for divorce from her husband of
21 years on her talk show Monday I'm
moving out a sober house in just a few
days you know it'll be wet until now
Hunter has been Williams manager and an
executive producer of her TV show but
according to a report he might be out of
a job and fast
TMZ claims the two are close to reaching
quote and accord whereby he'd stepped
down from his role on the show ET sat
down with Wendy's longtime friend Paul
Porter in March and he weighed in on
Williams marriage to Hunter and their
longtime business partnership they built
an empire together of course Kevin came
in a little later in I mean Kevin's
bless he never finished the ninth grade
and they built you know tens of millions
of dollars together
[Music]